Catedrática Tamar Gendler: Hoy
quiero terminar la clase
de la semana pasada sobre
el utilitarismo
y después pasar a la clase que
mejor representa el eslogan
"hombre muerto los martes",
en todo el semestre.
Veremos una explicación
filosófica de Immanuel Kant.
Para compensar el hecho
de que la segunda parte de la
clase es bastante árida,
tendremos un par de preguntas para
votar en la primera parte.
Como recordarán de
nuestra clase pasada,
en los fragmentos del utilitarismo que
leímos de John Stuart Mill,
él explica dos cosas muy famosas
que están en el centro de la
visión utilitaria.
Primero, explica el principio
de la mayor felicidad.
Es un principio que se
supone que nos dice
cómo es un acto moralmente correcto.
Mill dice que hay una
relación proporcional
entre la corrección de un
acto y lo que produce.
En particular, una
relación proporcional
entre la corrección de un acto y la
cantidad de felicidad que produce,
sin importar cómo se
distribuye dicha felicidad.
Dice: "las acciones son correctas
en la medida en que tienden a
promover la felicidad
y son incorrectas en la medida en que
tienden a promover lo contrario",
y la felicidad que nos interesa no es
la felicidad del propio agente
sino "la felicidad de todos
los interesados".
La segunda cosa famosa que dice
en los primeros pasajes
del Utilitarismo es que el motivo por
el cual se realiza un acto
es irrelevante para el
valor moral del mismo.
Dice que el motivo no tiene nada que ver
con la moralidad de la acción.
"Quien salva a una criatura de ahogarse
hace lo que es moralmente correcto,
sin importar si su motivo es el deber o
la esperanza de una recompensa".
Podríamos resumir estos principios
diciendo que el primero afirma que lo
que importa de la moralidad
de un acto es la cantidad total
de felicidad que produce.
Lo que nos importa son los
grupos, no los individuos.
Nos interesa cuánto bien
se hace en general,
no dónde podrían caer
esas piezas de bien.
El segundo principio nos dice
que el utilitario,
que a fin de cuentas es un
consecuencialista,
está interesado en las consecuencias.
Está interesado en el
resultado de la acción,
no en el proceso mediante el cual
se logró dicho resultado.
Lo primero que leímos para la clase
pasada era una selección
del Utilitarismo de Mill donde
explicaba estos principios.
Es importante reconocer que estos
principios entienden muy bien
en qué estamos pensando
cuando intentamos explicar
qué hay detrás de
nuestros juicios morales.
Parece ser cierto que nos
interesa cómo es el mundo
después de realizar una
acción en particular,
y la medida en la que nos
interesa cómo es el mundo,
nuestro interés principal,
no es cómo ocurrieron los asuntos
sino cómo resultaron.
Nuestra principal preocupación
cuando adoptamos una postura moral,
no se centra en cuánto
bien tenemos nosotros
sino en cuánto bien hay en
general en el mundo.
Desde que surgió el utilitarismo,
ha tenido una serie
clásica de objeciones,
algunas las abordaremos en la clase
de hoy y algunas ya las vimos
en los fragmentos de Bernard Williams
que leímos la clase pasada.
Recordarán que el debate de Williams
empieza con la historia de Jim,
un hombre que llega a una
aldea sudamericana
gobernada por un vaquero
muy desagradable.
Algunos habitantes
se han quejado de la autoridad de
este vaquero desagradable.
El vaquero desagradable
ha reunido a 20 aldeanos y,
para demostrar su poder,
tiene pensado matarlos.
Cuando Jim llega, Pedro, el vaquero,
le dice que si está dispuesto a
disparar a uno de los aldeanos,
los otros 19 serán liberados.
Ese es el caso de Jim.
Jim llega a un pueblo.
El gobernante del pueblo ha seleccionado
a 20 personas al azar para matarlas,
pero si Jim está dispuesto a matar a
una, las otras 19 serán liberadas.
Saquen sus clickers.
Pregunta: En este caso, ¿cuál es
la obligación moral de Jim?
¿Es moral que Jim le
dispare a una persona
y así libere a las otras 19?
¿O debería negarse a dispararle
y dejar que las 20 mueran?
Veamos los resultados.
Más de 3/4 de la clase
piensa que lo correcto moralmente es
que Jim mate a una persona
y así libere a las otras 19.
La próxima semana hablaremos más
de este tipo de cuestiones.
Nuestra lectura para el jueves
es una serie de dilemas morales
con esta estructura.
Al 77% que respondió que "sí"
quiero preguntarles si piensan
que darían el siguiente paso natural para
los utilitarios según Williams.
Williams argumenta que si
son utilitarios
y piensan que es moralmente correcto
que Jim mate a una persona y
libere a las otras 19,
no deberían sentir ningún
reparo moral por su acción.
Está claro lo que se tiene que hacer.
Lo correcto es matar a una
para salvar a 19.
Deberían sentir desaprobación moral
hacia Pedro, que puso a Jim
en esta situación.
Pero no deberían sentir
desaprobación moral
hacia Jim y algo muy
importante, según Williams,
es que Jim no debería sentir
ningún reparo moral.
Entre el 77% que respondieron
que Jim hizo lo correcto
al matar a uno para salvar a 19,
¿piensan que Jim debería
considerar sus vacilaciones
como meros escrúpulos y buscar
la forma de superarlos?
¿O consideran que Jim debería tener
en cuenta sus vacilaciones
al hacer lo que los utilitarios y
ustedes dijeron que era lo correcto?
¿Debería considerar sus vacilaciones
como un indicador de algo
moralmente relevante?
Más o menos 70 personas
tendrían que responder a esto.
Veamos cómo salen los resultados.
La mayoría solamente adopta
una parte de la idea consecuencialista,
por lo menos de la forma como
lo define Williams.
La mayoría piensa que lo
correcto, en este caso,
es que Jim mate a uno para
salvar a los otros 19,
pero no consideran que Jim
debería aprobar esta
acción sin reservas.
Más tarde, veremos la
analogía de Williams
al caso de racismo residual
para entender por qué
alguien que adopta la noción
consecuencialista completa
considera que esta
combinación de opiniones
que tienen ustedes, que
piensan que lo correcto
es matar a uno para salvar a 19,
pero también piensan que lo correcto
es sentirse mal al respecto,
no les permite aprovechar en su
totalidad la postura utilitaria
como una forma para
entender la moralidad.
Como bien saben, Williams nos
presenta dos casos.
El primer caso es el que les
acabo de explicar,
el caso de Jim y los indios cautivos.
El segundo caso, al más
puro estilo de los 70,
se trata de un hombre que
necesita volver a trabajar
porque es muy difícil que su
mujer trabaje fuera de casa.
Les digo esto con mero
interés histórico.
La oferta de trabajo que tiene
George, en el ejemplo de Williams,
es en un laboratorio de
armas biológicas
y George se opone moralmente a ello.
Si George no acepta el trabajo en el
laboratorio de armas biológicas,
otra persona más belicosa,
dispuesta a abogar
por el uso de las armas
biológicas en todos los
contextos,
obtendrá el trabajo.
Los dos casos que nos presenta Williams
tienen una estructura común.
Es una estructura común
que veremos repetirse en
los dilemas morales.
Hay una acción que da un
resultado determinado
y hay otra acción que da un
resultado diferente,
y el primer acto aparentemente
es peor que el segundo.
Jim tiene la posibilidad de
dispararle a una persona
o a ninguna.
Esas son sus opciones.
Si Jim hace lo primero,
dispararle a una persona,
entonces 19 personas serán liberadas;
si Jim hace lo segundo, no
dispara a nadie
y rechaza la oferta de Pedro, entonces,
morirán 20 personas.
De la misma forma, George
tiene la opción
de aceptar el trabajo en el
laboratorio de armas biológicas
o no aceptarlo.
Si George acepta el trabajo
en el laboratorio,
la otra persona belicosa no
conseguirá trabajo
y el resultado será mejor.
Si George no acepta el trabajo,
entonces, la otra persona
belicosa obtendrá el trabajo
y el resultado será peor.
En ambos casos tenemos 2 acciones,
matar contra no matar,
aceptar el trabajo contra no
aceptar el trabajo,
una es peor que la otra, pero sus
resultados están invertidos.
Los consecuencialistas nos dicen que
no miremos el lado del acto,
sino el lado del resultado.
Los consecuencialistas dicen
que las únicas cosas que
debemos considerar,
es cuánta gente se salva
o cuánta investigación se
realiza en armas biológicas.
Según los consecuencialistas,
debemos ver que el resultado 1
es mejor que el 2, y volver a
interpretar a partir de eso,
así decidimos qué deberíamos hacer.
Deberíamos hacer la primera acción
porque es la que produce el
mejor resultado.
Los partidarios de la deontología o
de la ética de las virtudes
no están de acuerdo.
Dicen que no vayamos directo
a la consecuencia,
que también veamos lo que
necesita hacer el individuo
para lograr dicha consecuencia.
Considerando que el acto 1
es peor que el 2,
la deontología o la ética
de las virtudes dicen
que por lo menos es importante
tomar en serio la posibilidad
de que hacer lo correcto, en estos
casos, sería la segunda acción,
aunque el resultado sea peor.
Williams señala que si tomamos en
serio la primera acción,
en la que estamos viendo el resultado
y no el proceso que generó
dicho resultado,
entonces cualquier
vacilación que sintamos,
para lograr ese resultado derivado
de un acto en particular,
se debe a cierto tipo de escrúpulos.
El utilitario afirma,
y por eso empezamos con citas de Mill,
que es irrelevante moralmente pensar
en quién realiza un acto
o en quién obtiene los bienes.
Lo que importa según el
principio de la mayor felicidad,
es cuánta felicidad se
produce en total;
no importa, a menos que afecte a
la cantidad de felicidad,
quién produce dicha felicidad
o a dónde se va dicha felicidad.
En la visión
consecuencialista hay cabida
para
el pensamiento de segundo orden sobre la
distribución de la felicidad.
Si las injusticias brutas en la
cantidad de felicidad en una sociedad
producen menos felicidad,
podemos tomar esto en consideración.
Si realizar una acción determinada
produce menos felicidad en un individuo,
podemos tomar esto en consideración.
En última instancia,
lo único que sirve para determinar
si un acto es moralmente correcto
es la cantidad de felicidad
y no dónde se distribuye
dicha felicidad.
Como señalaba Epicteto,
algunas cosas dependen de
nosotros y otras no.
Cuando Jim llega al poblado de Pedro,
una cosa que no depende de él es
el hecho de ser forzado
a elegir entre las opciones
que Pedro le presenta.
Sin decir que lo que Pedro
le pide es atroz.
Pero la estructura de la
situación que Jim enfrenta
es muy sencilla.
Pedro matará a 20 personas
o si Jim mata a una, las
otras 19 vivirán.
Eso es lo que tiene que decidir Jim.
Sin embargo, el 75% del 75%
piensa que Jim hizo lo
correcto en esa situación
y que debería sentir algún tipo de
escrúpulo por haberlo hecho.
Williams destaca que si tomamos en serio
la noción consecuencialista,
tal vez, sería correcto moralmente
intentar cultivar en nosotros
sentimientos morales
que vayan de acuerdo con
nuestros juicios morales.
Mediante la argumentación
racional y la reflexión,
aunque estén comprometidos
con la igualdad racial,
con la igualdad sin
distinción de género,
contra la discriminación por la edad,
contra la discriminación por
una discapacidad física,
podrían darse cuenta de que como
resultado de haber vivido
en una sociedad estructurada
que codifica cierto tipo de
racismo residual,
sexismo y homofobia,
ustedes mismos tienen ciertos
sentimientos que los llevan
a responder instantáneamente de
formas que van en contra
de sus compromisos morales.
En esos casos,
considero que piensan que hay
algún mandato moral
sobre ustedes para intentar deshacerse
de esas respuestas instintivas.
Si realmente están en
contra del racismo,
desean en la medida de lo posible
tener un alma armoniosa
al participar en
encuentros interraciales.
Si su razón les dice que están
comprometidos contra el racismo,
desean que su espíritu y su apetito
estén alineados de la misma manera.
Hay casos en los que la
moralidad, al reflexionar,
nos dice que algo es correcto, y
la consecuencia de esto
sobre nuestro comportamiento implica
que intentemos cultivar instintos
que se correspondan con esto.
Williams dice que el
utilitario debería pensar,
en casos como el de Jim, que Jim es
como el racista residual.
Sabe qué es lo correcto,
pero tiene una tendencia
residual a ser llevado
en la dirección moralmente incorrecta.
Si no consideran que es cierto que Jim
debería cambiar su actitud
en ese caso, y piensan que el
racista implícito residual
debería intentar cambiar su actitud,
podría serles útil pensar
en cuál es la diferencia
entre esos dos casos.
Con esto quiero concluir
el tema del utilitarismo
y sus críticas.
Retomaremos estos temas dos veces más:
el jueves cuando leamos el
problema del tranvía
de Judy Thomson
y el martes
cuando veamos algunos trabajos
empíricos al respecto,
que proponen una
explicación naturalista
de por qué Jim siente esa vacilación.
Ahora quiero presentarles
el tercer panorama moral
que estudiaremos este semestre.
La clase pasada vimos a detalle
las teorías morales consecuencialistas
a través de John Stuart Mill.
Esas teorías colocan el valor moral de
un acto en sus consecuencias.
En la primera parte de la clase,
dedicamos mucho tiempo a la teoría
de la virtud de Aristóteles,
que colocaba el valor moral de
un acto en el actor.
Recuerden que vimos que los
actos tenían valor moral
solo si se realizaban como resultado
de un tipo de constancia del carácter.
Hoy veremos la tercera parte
de esta historia,
una visión moral que dice que la
moralidad de una acción
no es el resultado de cómo es el actor,
no es el resultado de cuáles
son sus consecuencias,
sino que es el acto en sí mismo.
En particular, veremos la teoría
deontológica de Immanuel Kant.
Immanuel Kant era un filósofo
alemán, del siglo XVIII,
que al igual que Platón y Aristóteles
proporcionó una teoría filosófica
sistemática y completa que hasta el
día de hoy se toma en serio
como una forma para dar sentido
al mundo en general.
Kant tiene teorías de metafísica, es
decir, el tipo de cosas que existen.
Tiene teorías de
epistemología, es decir,
cómo sabemos el tipo de
cosas que existen.
Tiene teorías de ética, es decir,
cuál es la acción correcta.
Tiene teorías de estética, es decir,
qué otorga un valor
estético a las cosas.
Kant expresó sus opiniones sobre
estos tres principales dominios
de la filosofía en tres
enormes y densos libros:
el primero, La crítica de
la razón pura,
explica cómo es el mundo y
cómo sabemos que es así,
lo escribió en 1781 y después
hubo revisiones corregidas;
el segundo, La crítica de
la razón práctica,
es una explicación de la
naturaleza de la moralidad;
y el tercero, La crítica del juicio,
es una explicación de la
naturaleza del valor estético.
Además de esos densos trabajos,
Kant también escribió
presentaciones más
populares de su visión.
En el caso de la metafísica,
escribió Prolegomenos a toda
metafísica futura.
En el caso de la ética,
escribió Fundamentación para una
metafísica de las costumbres,
que obviamente es el texto del que
leímos fragmentos para hoy.
Les doy este contexto
porque quiero que sepan
que aunque lo que leímos
fue muy difícil,
elegí tal vez la parte más fácil
del libro más fácil de Kant.
¿Qué deberían llevarse de Kant
si logran llevarse algo?
Si logran llevarse algo de
su lectura de Kant,
me gustaría que se llevaran la idea
del imperativo categórico.
Mi objetivo del resto de la clase
es leer juntos el texto de Kant
que teníamos para hoy,
para lograr que ustedes puedan entender
lo que Kant quiere decir con
imperativo categórico.
Dependiendo de cómo vayan los
siguientes 20 minutos,
haremos esto justo al final
de la clase de hoy
o al inicio de la del jueves.
Veamos el texto de Kant.
El libro Fundamentación para una
metafísica de las costumbres
comienza con un pasaje muy
famoso que dice:
"nada puede ser considerado
bueno sin restricción,
excepto la buena voluntad".
Esto debería sonarles
conocido a ustedes
que han leído el Libro II de La
República de Platón.
Es la clásica distinción entre las
cosas que tienen valor intrínseco
y las que solo tienen
valor instrumental.
Muy al estilo del Sócrates de Platón,
Kant enumera algunas cosas que
caen en la otra categoría,
la de las cosas que solo tienen
utilidad instrumental.
Kant dice que entre las cosas que
no pueden considerarse
como buenas sin restricción están
los talentos de la mente
como la inteligencia y el ingenio, las
cualidades del temperamento
como el valor y la perseverancia,
los dones de la fortuna como el poder,
las riquezas, el honor y la salud.
Se burla directamente de Aristóteles
y dice que tampoco las virtudes...
-¡Ay, no! ¿Cómo puedo
cerrar ese correo?-.
Kant dice que tampoco las virtudes
antiguas como la moderación
y el autocontrol pueden ser
consideradas como buenas en sí
mismas.
¿Por qué? Porque aunque ser
inteligente, valiente, rico
o controlado les ayudará a
alcanzar sus metas,
esas virtudes no determinan las metas.
Esas virtudes magnifican su
efectividad como un agente,
pero no determinan el valor de
sus actos como agentes.
Kant dice que un ladrón ingenioso,
perseverante, rico, saludable
y moderado será un excelente ladrón,
pero eso no hará que sus
acciones sean buenas.
También dice que todas las
virtudes que tradicionalmente
han sido ensalzadas como tales,
obtienen su valor solo si la buena
voluntad las acompaña.
La buena voluntad no es buena a
causa de lo que afecta
o lo que logra, es buena en sí misma.
Cuando digo que Kant es un
crítico del consecuencialismo
no estoy exagerando.
Kant no piensa que el resultado de
un acto es lo que importa.
En un pasaje muy famoso,
famoso en parte
debido a la traducción un poco
confusa que nos ha llegado, dice:
"la buena voluntad
seguirá siendo buena,
aunque por la mezquindad de una
naturaleza madrastra
careciera completamente de poder
para alcanzar su propósito".
Con esto quiere decir que si ustedes
a pesar de su buena voluntad
vieran frustradas sus metas,
sus acciones seguirían
teniendo valor moral.
De forma más poética y con un
vocabulario más común
para el oído moderno,
Kant dice, aunque no lograra
alcanzar sus metas
"brillaría como una joya
con su propia luz,
como algo que tiene valor en sí mismo.
Ni la utilidad ni la esterilidad pueden
añadir ni quitar nada a su valor."
La pregunta es:
¿Cómo podría alguien pensar esto?
¿Cómo podría alguien pensar
que lo que importa para determinar
si una acción es moral
no es el resultado que produce,
sino la descripción bajo la cual
se hace dicha acción?
Quiero ubicarlos
dentro del panorama kantiano
para que entiendan cómo es
su visión del mundo.
En los pasajes que leímos para hoy,
Kant hace tres
afirmaciones en
particular.
Dice que una acción debe
realizarse por deber
para tener valor moral.
La primera idea que quiero explicarles
es la noción kantiana de
algo hecho por deber.
Una acción hecha por deber, dice
Kant en su segunda propuesta,
tiene su valor moral no en el propósito
que se alcanzará al realizarla,
sino en la máxima según la
cual se determina.
La forma en que una
acción hecha por deber
tiene valor moral no es viendo el
resultado que se espera de ella,
sino viendo bajo qué
caracterización se realizó dicha
acción.
Voy a explicar en detalle
qué significan esos términos.
Finalmente, dice Kant, en el centro de
la teoría moral deontológica
está la idea de que
"el deber es la necesidad de una
acción por respeto a la ley".
Kant considera que solo cuando someten
su voluntad a su propia ley,
es decir, a la ley moral que ustedes
reconocen que tiene fuerza
sobre sus propios actos,
es la única circunstancia en la
que son realmente libres.
Kant dice:
"el deber es la necesidad de una
acción por respeto a la ley"
cuando realizan una acción por
respeto a la ley moral,
solo en ese caso actúan de
forma autónoma.
Tres agudas afirmaciones
increíblemente complicadas de
Kant.
Intentemos ver qué significan.
Comencemos con la primera,
la afirmación de que un
acto tiene valor moral
solamente cuando se realiza por deber.
Kant señala que podríamos tener
3 tipos de motivaciones
para realizar una acción:
Podríamos hacerlo por deber,
por inclinación
o por interés propio.
Solamente los casos del
primer tipo, de hecho,
solamente los casos puros del
primer tipo tienen valor moral.
Las acciones que solo se
hacen por cumplir,
pero no por deber moral, no tienen
valor moral según Kant.
Si obedecen la ley por puro
interés propio,
su obediencia, no tiene valor
moral según Kant.
Si rescatan a un niño que se
está ahogando en una laguna
solo porque hay una señal que dice
"Recompensa por rescatar a un niño
ahogándose: 1 millón de dólares",
su acto no tiene valor moral.
Podemos pensar en lo que
representa la afirmación de Kant
y en cómo difiere de las
otras que hemos estudiado
viendo la cuestión del espacio
en un diagrama de flujo.
Queremos saber si una acción
determinada tiene valor moral
y lo primero que hacemos
es preguntarnos:
¿La acción se
corresponde con el deber?
Si la respuesta es no, es decir,
si han mentido, robado, matado
o permitido que algo terrible
pasara ante ustedes
aunque fácilmente hubieran
podido evitarlo,
sin consecuencias para ustedes, todos
los autores que hemos leído,
coinciden obviamente en que ese
acto no tiene valor moral.
¿Eso se alcanza a ver?
Se supone que está en color
rojo sobre negro.
¿No se ve nada desde atrás?
¡Qué lástima!
lo que está en color rojo dice
"no mentir, no robar".
No puedo cambiarlo en todas
las diapositivas,
pero les iré leyendo lo que dice.
Ok. La segunda pregunta que nos hacemos,
habiendo eliminado ya del
reino del valor moral
aquellas acciones que no se
corresponden con el deber,
es: ¿Con qué motivo se
hizo la acción?
Tal vez, ustedes actúan de
forma moralmente valiosa
por interés propio sin
inclinaciones inmediatas.
Pagan sus impuestos porque
si no lo hacen,
tendrán que pagar más impuestos.
Respetan los límites de velocidad
solo porque tienen miedo de que
la policía los vea.
Mill dice que esos actos
tienen valor moral.
Kant dice que no.
Ese texto debería estar en rojo
pero ahora es invisible.
Supongamos que realizan un
acto de tal forma
que tienen una inclinación a
cumplir con el deber.
Kant piensa que ustedes tienen el
deber de no suicidarse,
y examina el caso en el que no se
suicidan porque son felices.
Kant piensa que deben ser
fieles a sus parejas,
pero dice que no tiene valor moral
mantenerse fieles a sus parejas
mientras están enamorados.
No tiene valor moral ser amable
con alguien con quien tienen afinidad.
Porque en esos casos, aunque
sus acciones cumplen
con lo que exige la moralidad,
no las realizan porque sean lo correcto.
Las realizan porque su
inclinación está alineada
con lo que la moralidad les exige.
Obviamente, Aristóteles
consideró que en esta situación
el valor moral está expresado
de forma paradigmática.
Pero Kant piensa que en esos casos
no se puede decir que un acto se haya
realizado desde la ley moral.
Solo pueden ver que se hizo para
cumplir con la ley moral,
que se corresponde con lo que
exige la ley moral,
pero no podemos deducir que el
motivo fue el deber.
Solo en el tercer caso,
donde actúan por deber
sin ninguna inclinación ni
interés propio,
Kant considera que es posible ver el
valor moral de una acción.
Si conservan su vida
cuando sienten la inclinación
a hacer lo contrario,
si son amables cuando no hay
ningún premio para ustedes
o cuando no sienten simpatía,
en esos casos, dice Kant,
podemos ver que la acción se
hace no solo por cumplir
sino desde la ley moral.
Esto no quiere decir que Kant
piense que una vida vivida
como Aristóteles sugería, sea
una vida mal vivida.
Los casos en los que la inclinación
está alineada con el deber
los mantienen fuera de esta
casilla de hacer lo incorrecto,
pero no les permiten poner a
prueba su carácter
y ver por ustedes mismos
que la motivación que tuvieron
para hacer lo correcto
es para cumplir con lo que la
ley moral les exige.
Al comprender qué significa
actuar desde el deber,
podemos entender la segunda
afirmación de Kant
en nuestra lectura para hoy.
Entonces "una acción hecha por deber,
no tiene su valor moral en el propósito
que se obtendrá al realizarla,
sino en la máxima bajo la cual se
determinó la acción".
Recuerden que hemos aprendido que
una acción hecha por deber
es aquella que se hace en conformidad
con lo que la moralidad exige,
porque es lo que la moralidad exige.
No porque tengan un interés propio,
no porque sientan la inclinación a
comportarse de esa manera,
sino porque esa acción es lo que
la moralidad les exige.
Para determinar si un acto es lo
que la moralidad les exige,
ese acto necesita tener una
descripción particular para ustedes.
La forma en que ustedes
describen dicho acto
utiliza lo que Kant
denomina una máxima,
un principio subjetivo de voluntad,
una descripción de algo sobre
ustedes, los sujetos,
que indica cuáles son sus deseos
para comportarse en esa situación.
Un principio subjetivo de
voluntad, es decir,
una descripción bajo la cual
se realiza el acto.
Tal vez, podría ejemplificarse así:
"A todas las personas que
vengan a mi tienda,
les diré honestamente cuánto vale
la negociación que hagamos,
sin importar si podría mentirles
sin que se dieran cuenta".
O: "A todas aquellas personas débiles
que necesiten mi ayuda,
se las daré sin importar si
eso me beneficiará".
"Solo considerando el motivo y no
considerando el resultado,
la acción puede expresar la buena
voluntad por sí misma".
"La buena voluntad es la única cosa
buena en sí misma" dice Kant,
y solo mirando la descripción bajo
la cual se realiza un acto
podemos determinar si la buena
voluntad estuvo implicada
de forma correcta en la elección
para realizar dicha acción.
Tercera afirmación:
"El deber es la necesidad de una
acción por respeto a la ley".
Sabemos que un acto tiene valor moral
solo si se realiza por deber.
Sabemos que para que se
realice por deber
necesita hacerse bajo
cierta descripción.
Ahora nos explica qué
significa ese deber.
Kant dice que para que un acto
sea hecho por deber,
debe hacerse con el
reconocimiento explícito
de que se está respetando la ley moral
en la medida en que exprese lo
que la moralidad exige.
No en la medida en que exprese
que ustedes podrían tener un alma bien
ordenada, armoniosa y feliz.
No en la medida en que exprese
cómo podrían distribuirse
montones de felicidad
entre montones de personas.
Sino por el respecto, dice Kant,
por el hecho de que es lo que
la moralidad les exige.
El valor moral de un acto, dice
Kant, no está en su efecto,
puesto que el efecto pudo haberse
obtenido de varias formas.
Podría tener la intención de liberar
un gas biológico en el metro
para matar a miles de personas,
pero como no soy bueno para la química,
el resultado es que produzco
una gran cantidad de felicidad
para esas personas.
El efecto puede lograrse
de varias formas.
Kant dice que Mill
consideraría que liberar ese
gas
es un acto con valor moral.
Kant dice: No,
lo que importa es la descripción
bajo la cual se realiza el acto
y en especial que dicha descripción
muestre que respetamos la
ley por sí misma.
Les dije que llegaríamos al punto
del imperativo categórico
y voy a terminar la clase
de hoy justo ahí,
y en la próxima clase lo
veremos con mayor detalle.
Entonces, la pregunta es esta.
Es una pregunta apremiante y
apasionante de Kant.
Sé que estamos en la visión
de Kant de las cosas,
pero esto es muy emocionante.
"¿Qué tipo de ley…?", dice Kant.
Incluso pone un "pero" para
hacerlo más emocionante.
Suspenso…
"¿Qué tipo de ley puede
determinar la voluntad
sin hacer referencia a ninguna
intención de esperar un efecto,
para que la voluntad sea
considerada completamente buena
sin restricción?".
¡Es muy emocionante!
Vamos a descubrir algo que nos
hará realmente autónomos,
libres y morales.
Recuerden: no puede ser
nada en particular,
no puede ser nada específico del mundo
o sus resultados.
¿Qué puede ser?
Puede ser la conformidad universal de
las acciones de la voluntad
con la ley como tal.
Es decir, lo que hace que una
ley sea vinculante
es el hecho de que sea reconocida
por todos los agentes
racionales como vinculante.
En particular, adopta la forma
de lo que Kant denomina
el imperativo categórico.
Aquí está la formulación del
imperativo categórico
en nuestra lectura para hoy:
"Obren solo según aquella máxima
que quieran que se convierta
en una ley universal".
Nunca hagan nada
que no les gustaría que todos los
demás hicieran también.
La próxima clase comenzaremos
con el ejemplo que Kant usa para esto,
concretamente la promesa falsa,
hablaremos un poco sobre
varias formulaciones
del imperativo categórico y después
pasaremos al problema del
tranvía de Judy Thomson.